تمام تمام
[موسيقى]
الخاطئ بكلمه الرجيم
للاطفال
الحرمان الحقيقي هو لما نكون في سمنه
ونتحرموا من العيش في جسم مثالي وصحي
[موسيقى]
36 سنه دكتور في التغذيه الرياضيه مستشار
في الرياضه من الجزائر
[موسيقى]
بنتي هو انت اديتوكس
صحه اولادي هي الاستثمار في الاهتمام بصحه
الاولاد في السوبر
القدرات الجسميه والبدنيه
ويعيش بها ويكمل بها كامل جدا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاطفال غير واعيين حتى وين الحكومه السن
المراهقه هنا بدو يحسوا بالتعب النفسي
كروشي الطفل لما يجيلي مركز الفيت نحاول
انه نتعامل معه بطريقه
ذكيه اللي تخليه انه يتقبل هذا المفهوم
الجديد في شخصيته وايضا ياخذ البرنامج
الغذائي دياله وهو فرحان وهو يطلب
في اسرع وقت ممكن يخرج بتحدي كبير وبرغم
شديده في التغيير
الاطفال بطريقه كبيره بزاف وهي الفيديوهات
اللي نعملها عبر صفحه الفيسبوك
والانستغرام مع الاطفال وحده اخرين اللي
نجحوا في هذا البرنامج الشيء اللي خلاه
هذا الاطفال يحاولوا انهم يلحقوا لنفس
النتيجه يلحقها هذا الاولاد اللي عملت
معهم المقابلات التحفيزيه
[موسيقى]
الطفل لازم يفهم انه في كلمه رجيم معروف
في عقوبه انما راح يعني يتبدل في نمط صحي
جديد وراح يلحق للجسم مثالي بطريقه
بسيكولوجيه ذكيه نحاولوا اننا نلحقوا هذا
الرساله
[موسيقى]
قولوا هذا الرساله بطريقه ذكيه بطريقه
مبسطه لازم افهم مكونات الجسم او نسبه
الدهون الكتله العضليه وكل المكونات
رجيم النمط حياته ولازم على كل طفل انه
يتعلمه من الصغر ورسالتي للاولياء انهم
يمدوا اهميه كبيره للغذاء الصحي للاولاد
ديالهم
المشاكل الصحيه اللي تقدر تسبب من خلال
الغذاء الغير صحي ويحاولوا الاولاد تاعهم
النمط صحي جديد في حياتهم
[موسيقى]